- If I mess up, I
immediately will have a knee
to the face.
(intense music)
- So today, I'm going to
shave my girlfriend's legs
for the first time.
- Please don't hurt me.
- I'm not going to hurt you.
- Please.
You are shaking a lot.
- I know, I'm really nervous.
- I think if anything, he'll go softer
and maybe at first not get the hair
and then when he tries
to get the hair more
he'll end up nicking me.
- I love him right now
in this current state
with my hairy legs before he
has done anything to them.
- You're going to love me after.
- My expectations are that I'm
going to do a flawless job.
- What happens if I do a bad job?
- What happens if you do a bad job?
I don't want to think about that.
I'm already shaking.
(intense music)
- This part's actually kind of nice.
This parts like getting a pedicure,
only Mike can't yell mean things about me
in another language.
- This is how you do it?
(laughs)
You're like barely touching me.
- You just want to keep it like...
- Give it.
- This is a good razor.
He's like I got this like oh.
- How did you cut me?
- The first cut (laughs).
- You cut me first.
- Oh my goodness.
- This is how I do it.
I don't know how you do it.
- Have you ever seen a girl
like even in a commercial shave her legs?
- No, I've never seen that.
- Oh, okay.
- Never in my life.
- We don't do it going down,
we do it going up.
- Oh, for God's sake.
(intense music)
- Okay, this is delightful,
but there's no way your shaving here.
You're definitely just
like getting shaving cream.
- Too soft?
- Definitely too soft.
- Why would you go up?
- Because you're supposed to go against
the grain of the hair.
- Oh boy, the shin is thin.
Okay, you did good.
We survived the shin (laughs).
I didn't expect that.
I'm very impressed.
- I'm doing (laughs)
an incredible job.
- Um.
- What?
Does that hurt, did it hurt?
- No, but it's interesting.
You're going so soft that I almost wonder
if I'm still going to have hair.
- God, be careful.
- Don't move while I'm cutting.
- Because I just saw you just go at it
from a hacked job angle.
That's just like looked horrible.
- This is the part I'm nervous about.
- All gone.
Oh, the part with the scab?
- The shin, cause yeah,
even I'll nick myself there.
(gasps)
- It's the part that was already--
- But look, it's going to bleed now.
- It's just a little.
- I'm sorry, you're beautiful.
You're beautiful, you're beautiful.
- Honey, you know--
- (laughs) You're shaving my foot.
- There's cream there.
- Are you shaving my foot?
- Oh, I can see your muscles shaking.
- Twitching (laughs).
- Besides from a couple little strays,
he did a pretty good job.
- To me strays are a
lot better than blood.
- I think Matt did really, really well.
He did nick me, it's going to hurt.
- That was so much more stressful
than I thought it was going to be.
- (laughs) That was actually not as bad
as I thought it was going to be.
- I mean, you did really good.
You got all the hair.
You had a weird technique.
It was like a kitty pawing at a leg.
- For a first timer he did great.
- You have really nice legs,
which I discovered today.
- Just today?
- I still love you.
- Okay, good, that's really important.
- Even after you shaved my leg.
(whistling)
- He's getting over confident,
the whistling starts.
I feel like I'm at like an
old timey barbershop (laughs).
- A barbershop for legs?
- Yeah.